dr. mark addicts from DIRECTV's
fantasies own kind enough to join its
dr. you know when you bring in the
ambulance and you got a police escort so
what was at stake here what a day what
were the precautions they were taking
with this with the dislocation as
opposed to just the torn ACL what when
you have a dissociation there's always
there's always the worry that you could
tear an artery which obviously makes it
more of a life and death situation and
you also can have nerve damage so it's
important to get them seen uh in a
hospital setting so they can evaluate it
quickly have doctors check the vitals
Alexei deal for pulses download not that
they couldn't do that on the field but
it's just a lot more of a high-stakes
injury what is a dislocation so I mean
essentially the end of your side bone
actually get dislocated from from the
top of the shin bone and I've actually
had the injury my second game is a pro I
was actually playing in the USFL and I
dislocated my knee and you know I mean
it was a horrific injury it was never
felt pain like it hope I never do and to
tell you the truth it's it's it's such a
tough recovery I was maybe seventy-five
percent back after a full year and never
got more than about 85-90 at most I mean
I did play nine more years in the league
but as a mobile quarterback I think it
affects you quite a bit more than a
pocket passer or or an offensive lineman
the so you're talking at least a year
for him to come back can you come back
and be a hundred percent or close to it
with that injury uh honestly I think 95
is about the most you can count on you
know I mean I think if you talk to guys
in the league are they ever really a
hundred percent anyway so I think you
can come back and play and play
effectively it's going to be a difficult
surgery it's going to be a very
difficult rehabilitation
it's possible for him to be back even in
nine months but but i but i think that
the first season back he's he's
definitely going to be probably twenty
percent off of worry was prior to this
injury and eventually maybe can get them
90 95 when you see Tony Romo gonna go
down he's got a broken bone in his back
and then they say six to ten weeks but
what from a doctor's perspective and
somebody who played football what does
that mean and at that position what is a
broken bone in your back mean at that
position well if you're talking about
the little bones that are on the very
back year spine or the or the transverse
processes which he broke two of the
transverse process a while back and only
missed a game this is a different injury
this is a compression fracture so the
big bones that really allow your spine
to stand up they got crushed and so this
compression fracture is more worrisome
it is a fracture that you generally see
in the elderly and so with him having to
transverse process fracture three
classical fractures and now now a
compression fracture in his lumbar spine
I the first thing I would want to do is
is check out a metabolic bone panel why
are his bone fracturing more because i
saw the injury wasn't super high impact
or anything III was surprised that he
has an injury that is going to require
him to miss you know they're saying six
to ten but it could be you know you
could talk three months out i mean it
could he take longer depending on how he
feels what is the injury now in football
that is less dangerous to your playing
career than say a generation ago acl's
are i mean i think people more reliably
heal from those I mean I I think that
we've got in sports medicine we have
gotten better at everything and in
orthopedics in general we have gotten
better we're starting to use biologics
stem cells and other things to help help
help people heal more reliably so I
think across the board we're better and
midas occurred back in 84 and so
certainly the surgeries are better
but it is regardless it is a much
tougher injury to come back from them
than just a straightforward ACL talking
teddy bridgewater's dislocation great to
talk to your doctor thanks for joining
us again Greg vanos reporter dr. mark
addicts from DIRECTV's fantasy zone so
on fantasy zone there they have him on
if there's an injury to anybody and he's
able to put it in layman's terms of what
it is and how long they're going to be
out but what happened and having been
around somebody who dislocated their
knee that the nervous part is is there
any nerve damage you know could could
you be you know it's an artery lose your
leg they were worried about that with
Marcus Lattimore against Tennessee they
didn't know because that that's all you
want to do when you when you have an ACL
it's one thing you'll always hear it did
it pop doctors will ask you your coaches
who asked you did it pop now if a popped
and then they know you you blew out your
knee but when it comes to a dislocation
it's completely different and that's
that's going to be the big challenge for
Teddy Bridgewater the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience